this class is specifically about end
games and I always whenever I think
about it end game I remember a comment
from a dear friend of mine his name was
Michael Frenette and he was many times
the champion of Washington State and I
was as I was growing up I was like 12 13
14 Mike would win the clothes washing
the state championship and he was
considered the strongest player in the
state so I would go up to Mike and I
would ask him and I said like you know
what do I have to do to get better
he said study your end games it's like
cheating on an exam okay explain that
one to me Mike says well the idea is if
you're gonna play chess and you're gonna
play a lot of chess games you're gonna
get to the ending so you might as well
study the endgame in anticipation of the
exam that you're inevitably going to
have yeah it's really hard to study the
endgame he says well don't study the yet
all of the engines just study rook
endings you know really he says yeah
because in the exam that's the place
where you're gonna get asked the most
questions you're gonna play more rook
endings and virtually any other endings
and indeed and as my career unfolded I
played lots of endings but many of them
featured rook endings so I'm going to
show you two rook endings today and it's
an absolute certainty as you become more
experienced as you play more chess games
with more tournament games you're gonna
get into rook ending of rook and four
versus rook on three on the same side of
the board it's just going to happen and
I chose these two rook endings from my
career
that I thought would be very good for
tonight's class
I played a match with vasilyev on shock
in Tilburg it's a city in Holland rule
not even sure what year it was ah 92
yeah there you go
1992 it's a two game match and in case
you played a 1-1 then you would play to
classical chest high breakers of 30
minutes per side
so in the first game I was black so I'm
going to do them out of order the game
was a draw and I got rook and four
versus rook and three and I couldn't win
it in the second game I was white I got
looking for versus rook in three and I
couldn't win it and as we started our
tie breaks before we started our
tiebreaker said Vasily if we get her a
rook ending where I had looking for and
you have rook in three I'm gonna claim
three time repetition and a draw to the
match unfortunately I didn't get my four
versus three and he has won the match in
tiebreaks but as opposed to going to the
game position that I want to go to we'll
just briefly look at how we got there
okay I did a lot of things in the
opening is why I played English's
Reddy's Queen pawns I pretty much stayed
away from efore except in the beginning
of my career I loved efore but it just
got too much theory and preparing for
Yvonne Chuck is a nightmare you know you
just have no idea what the guy's going
to do and the next thing I know we were
in a cattle land yeah I had my build a
fortress night
'if I've is as was seen in many of the
games between Viktor Korchnoi and
Anatoly Karpov from the 1978 World
Championship match Anatoly was defending
this gambit knight c6 and this was very
very popular at the time and as it still
remains popular today
black offers his pawn on c6 I took and
and played III so what my idea is is in
a in a nice wonderful world I will play
moves like I don't know Queen a 492
Knight takes bring my knight here to e5
and I'll have a wonderful position
Bishop a6 and so I'm a well we have this
very strange position where I've messed
up the Vasilis pawn structure but he has
very good play for his pieces and my
Bishop on C was not very good Knight d5
and we got to this position I played b3
so I have to do something to get my
pieces my Queen side pieces developed
and we got a position like this so I've
been a little bit better some of the
game and wearing a rook and four versus
rook and three so how many of you have
had rook and four versus through country
pretty good pretty good okay if white
has a chance of winning this position
his best setup is to have his King on g2
and his pawn on g4 once you have your
King on g2 in your pawn on g4 you have a
lot
of opportunities to press with g5 King
g4 and h5 or h5 h6 keeping blacks King
under pressure and almost an ideal
formation would be to have h6 g5 f 4e 3
4 vs 3 because then your pawns on h6 and
g5 are setting up all kinds of check
mating patterns so the kingside pawn
structure is actually quite critical and
one of the shocking things that I
learned from Viktor Korchnoi is that
when you're playing rook and 4 versus
rook and 3 what is the ideal pawn
structure for the defender
what is the defenders ideal pawn
structure in this case the ideal pawn
structure for black is f7 f6 King g7
pawn on h6 remarkably enough the doubled
F pawns really stop all of that all of
whites breaks so you've heard me just
talking about putting your pawns on g4
h5 h6 g5 bringing the king up obviously
blacks pawns are not doubled but if the
pawns were doubled you can see it's very
hard to play g4 g5 without at least
allowing one pawn to trade and it's very
hard to play E 4 E 5 also without
allowing at least one pawn to be traded
the goal of the defender is to trade as
many pawns as possible so in this
position one of the critical defensive
moves for black is this one other than
having the doubled F pawns this is
absolutely blacks best defensive
formation we can start to think about it
another way how are you going to win
this game with white if you play E 4 E
Phi
see 6 well black will just take it and
then it'll be three versus two have
pounds on g6 and and h5 easy defense
does it make any sense to prepare and
play f4 f5 well yes it does you could
play f4 f5 if the guy takes it you may
have a weakness over here but if black
puts his king on g6 he'll defend both
the weaknesses and so f4 f5 doesn't
really do it does it make any sense to
play f4 put your King on f3 play e4 put
your pawn on f5
well once again not really black is just
simply going to take it put his pawn on
f6 and make a very easy draw so it's a
very very hard against this structure
for white to do anything concrete
practically the only thing he can do is
play for g4 takes and play for h5 takes
get 2 versus once take your pawn on f6
put your pawn on e5 and somehow
checkmate black nice idea very very hard
to accomplish so we played lots of moves
but I was really really impressed by how
Yvan Chuck defended this ending in the
first place he put his rook on the
second rank keeping me a little bit
anchored so to speak to my f2 pawn it's
very hard to get an active King and you
can't really go King here King here when
you're losing your f2 pawn with check so
we've made some moves I didn't see
anything else I can't but in this moment
I can't really break with g3 g4 because
again my epon is my f2 pawn is a problem
so I did the next best thing that I
could I got it
[ __ ] off the second-ranked put my king
on f4 notice how very immediately from
blacks defensive point of view black
really has two ranks that he likes his
rook on he definitely likes his rook on
the second rank and he definitely likes
his rook on the fifth rank on the fifth
rank it cuts off my king ever wandering
up into blacks defensive area
efore and look how vastly just weights
he puts his King on g7 he just waits
finally kind of frustrated and don't
have too many ideas of how I can
continue I play f3 so now I'm frustrated
with the before I was frustrated when
his rook was on the second rank now I'm
frustrated when the rook is on the fifth
rank and I'm hoping to get in some kind
of you know I'm a pawn up I want to do
something with that pawn I want to push
it up the board and try to create a
passer rook so we just having some moves
and finally g4 yes
yes that's a very good question I'm not
sure myself
I think first of all I would have put
the rook on the third-ranked yeah and I
think that that would have forced me to
somehow bring my rook back to e3 I
suspect that this point
Vasiliy was entertaining a very strange
and dubious idea of playing f5 in the
case that black plays f5 I'm really
happy because at a certain moment when I
move my king he's gonna play Fe and I'll
play Fe and I'll have a passed pawn so I
think that this was just a a fake-out
misstep if you will so we just get to
this position I've done the best I can
I've achieved the maximum I'm able I
can't move my pawn forward so I play g4
takes takes and great I get an H fine so
now we have rook and two versus rook and
one and again it's going to take a lot
of cooperation by my opponent
unfortunately I would love to get my my
rook to the sixth rank Drive my
opponents King back play f4 and f5 F for
an e5 but even that is going to be a
draw and he stopped me right away by
putting my his pawn on f6 so he's
waiting so again i from the rook and
four versus rook and three I have I've
achieved the maximum I can and yet it's
still not enough and we made a draw okay
so let's go to the second the the the
second game which was actually the first
game so in the first game of the match I
was black and let's see it from the good
guys side okay actually this is a really
funny game and it I still remember it it
was really great
vasilyev on there's very interesting
face his eyebrows are very thick and
they actually seemed to come all the way
across I kind of in a Groucho Marx kind
of style and when he's at the board
thinking he's very expresses with his
eyebrows sometimes I like surprised and
the eyebrows will bounce up and down I
sacrificed a rook and when I made the
rook sacrifice it moved that he didn't
see the started what fluttering this was
a very funny game I liked in those days
I played lots of defenses myself but I
was always pretty true to the
nimzo-indian defense and I liked a
particular variation this this this
variation called the Rubinstein
variation than him so white is usually
playing for Bishop d3 Knight of three
castles and so on and I like to play
what was called the Huebner system with
c5 for those of you who remember the
1972 match between Bobby Fischer
and Laura Spassky Bobby Fischer 1 yes
check with black the I like black's
formation black is intent on playing 'if
I've and sometimes this pawn on c4 can
be a target and I've done quite well on
the black side of the system my results
were not lost on a von Schaack and he
plays this move Knight GE 2 which makes
a lot of sense right if black is
constantly threatening to duck capture
the knight and double the pawn
why not defend the knight play a2 a3 I
really like this line that anatoly
karpov played against Viktor Korchnoi in
the Baguio City match in 1978 Karpov on
the black side has played this this this
position so the move I played and it's a
really cool move and I liked it very
very much was this position I played 94
he played Bishop d2 I traded my knight
for his Bishop ok so I get rid of my
opponent's Bishop I lose time doing it
but now I played the move a5 and after a
3 takes takes Bishop d7 and my idea is
to play a four locking my opponent's
Queen side or rather shutting my
opponent's Queen side down so where my
opponent has an advantage that is to say
my opponent has a queen side majority my
intent with my pawn on a force to play
b6 and to keep my very strong center
pawns on e6 and d5 castles knight c6
rook e1 now why yes of course so he
played this move with the intention of
Knight takes d5 I took his pawn
he took my pawn bishop c6 Knight b6
attacking my rook my Kings in the center
and it's very very very complicated very
tricky position I had a cool move what
move did I play I played rook a5 whoo
and this is where the eyebrow started
going to help him down it was like whew
he didn't see that one that was a big
surprise and my idea of course there's
simply to take this pawn and then the
knight under mine so in this position
Yvan Chuck realized suddenly oops you
know this is like wily coyote you know
running after the roadrunner and he goes
off the cliff and then he keeps running
and he wakes up to the fact there's
nothing underneath him yeah
and now Reilly coyotes got to put on the
brakes and White has to desperately make
a draw from this position to try to save
the game I was very very impressed by
Yvan chuck in this game because he's
suddenly in a state of shock if he takes
the rook do we understand what would
happen if he takes the rook yeah this is
happening
this is the new variation light at the
top yep indeed night check and if he
takes cream g5 check and King h1 and mid
and what about what about King h1 same
thing
what's the same thing Queen I think I
was going to go Queen h4 yeah and then
h3 and then I was going to take the rook
and if he takes my knight and I take h3
and if in this position he goes check
whoo I got a move up and he takes her
rook the dove over it take my rooks
maybe it's still me after all the
pyrotechnics is still checkmate right in
right oh so now again he's got to
re-establish his bearings and try to
figure out how to hold the position he
came up with the best movie played rook
d1 I took upon so now I'm really happy
I'm a pawn up Bishop b4 getting rid of
my good minor pieces I took took castles
he played this so well you can see we're
about to get to rook and four versus
rook at three
now remember in the previous rook and
floor versus rook and three pawn it was
here and pawn was here it was like the
h4 h5 in this particular case yes I've
gotten in the much more you very very
important g5 versus the first endgame
rook over nonetheless I've got rooking
four versus rook and three and now I've
got to figure out what's my ideal setup
like I can put my pawn on h v e5 f5 you
know how how would you go about winning
this how what would you think White's
best winning strategy might be why do
you think what's the best setup for
what's the best I could do yeah well my
idea was that the best I could do is
maybe go h5 put my rook on the
fourth-ranked go h4 put my pawn on h3
and on a very good day go check and go
over and eat his H pawn it doesn't
really ever make sense to go like 'if
I've f-5e for f4 and III that pawn just
doesn't go anywhere White's King is
ideally places to stop the march of the
e pawn play G for h5 okay so again in my
fantasy I'm hoping that one day I'll be
able to put my pawn on f5 and I'll be
able to play h4 h 3 yeah that would be
cool hate that h3 now the problem for me
is if in this position
I play the move f5 what do you think is
that a good move just f5 a good move the
problem is is he takes takes any simply
waits let's say he waits by putting his
rook here and his King on g2 how on
earth can I make progress if I push my
pawn to e4 if I pardon me check here he
comes back
I can't play a 4e 5 is hanging and I'm
stuck
yes
it's re-put you're putting my rook weird
Arnie yeah
yes exactly rook king rook and let's say
wait yes well I can I can and then takes
I I have to take with the king and now I
have these split ponds which means it's
very very hard to make any further
progress sort of like Black has a very
easy time defending if I go down with
ideas like to do like this he comes back
behind me and gives a check and my king
can't find sank your sanctuary you will
just keep checking me and going after
this pawn on g4 so back here I thought
that one of my better options was to
take this pawn and force his rook into
this awkward situation I thought this
was my best chance was that somehow to
take advantage if I could put my pawn on
e4 I'll put his rook here and I'll put
my pawn on f5 and maybe I'll trap his
rook a little bit artificial I know he
had this move rook III why didn't I do
what I wanted I think the problem with
the immediate efore let me just show you
the variation that I was trying to
achieve was something like this where I
might be able to artificially isolate my
opponent's rook unfortunately this idea
also doesn't work why could play King g2
I move my rook and he could play three
and he breaks out
so I have played King here and I've
gotten this situation now my dream is
that I'll be able to play f4 King g4 f3
check now that would be winning if I
could get in the moves f4 King G for an
f3 check I would win the game
he checked me I thought that this was
very impressive defensive work
it turns out that the doubled F pawns
nothing nothing
whenever my King tries to go to e3
checks me here whenever my King tries to
go to g3 he checks me here whenever my
rook moves off the second-ranked
he plays King f2 so let me go back and
show this a little bit slowly from the
defensive point of view this is a really
really important point to remember is
that the doubled F pawns are a draw like
if we just magically take this H pawn
off the off the board it would still be
a draw
yes yes it's very important that this
pawn is here it's far too advanced if
the pawn were back then he'd I'd have
tricks of like King g3 and King f3 and
so forth but now with the pond so far
advanced we got this I was trying to
make some moves trying to trick him now
I'm hopeful please if there is a god I
go King f3 yes sir yes dare draw rook
behind yeah yeah the King trying but
without this pawn
there's no sanctuary from checks from
behind so here it was my last desperado
I'm trying to get in some kind of a king
up the board and trick him
this maneuver you're familiar with
philidor's maneuver that you do you just
keep your rook on the 3rd until this
other pawn moves out all the way up the
board and then you come right back down
there's like this pawn isn't even
important the extra pond
really doesn't help my cause so I tried
to trick him offering a trade of rooks
but this camp on endgame unfortunately
is a very easy draw and rather than
stalemate my opponent which is sometimes
kind of cool we made a draw here these
rook and pawn endgame positions of rook
and 4 versus rook and 3 are really
really
the meat and potatoes I want to say of
top chess masters it's almost almost a
given that the top grandmasters will
score maximum they'll make a draw
whether the defender will somehow figure
out how to win it when they have the
extra pawn I remember Magnus Carlsen
winning a looking for versus rook and
three against Kuryakin Sergei karyakin
but that was quite different White had a
weak weak pawn that Magnus could go
after any questions about this ending
this was a again just to repeat myself
that I thought that because the pawn
wasn't on h4 I have a little bit more
opportunities and it's quite possible
that already I have blown it remarkably
or blown it as a strong word but helped
my opponent I'll put it like that by
advancing this pawn too soon it might
have been much I might have been able to
put a little bit more pressure on Vasily
had I advanced my King with the idea of
h5h for from what we learned what do you
think how do you think blacks should
army how do you think white should
defend this position if you had white in
this position what would be your
approach
f-for I would like that to play against
that move because I would be able to
attack suddenly be able to attack this
pawn on f4 rook a7 I would like because
let me say rook here okay so go ahead
and make a suggestion
kingi to h4 go ahead and make a
suggestion
now again it's very very likely you're
going to get a rook and four versus rook
and three in the near future I'm not a
true sailor but okay what's a good move
for light now just waiting perhaps rook
c7 let's say we just wait let's say h4
well now after h3 I've created a little
bit more of an imbalance here probably
your very best move is to take with the
King if you take with the pond you're
giving me a passed pawn from the start
the reason I didn't play King g6 pardon
me it was because of remember that in
the earlier example how Vasily Gogh had
put his rook on the fourth I was worried
that if he plays rook here that his very
next turn will be to play h4 so for
example let's say I play h5 he plays h4
I advance my pawn he plays for
argument's sake rook here I advance my
pond he plays for argument's sake rook
here now it's very hard for me to go
running in with my king he's going to
put his king on g2 and stop me and at
when I get my king to say d4 he's gonna
come around and he's going to go after
my H pot so I'm gonna be anchored to my
H pawn in a short while
any questions it's all good yes yes
absolutely absolutely
there the differences let me just do
something these two rook and four versus
rook and three endings have to deal with
the fact that they're together right
this rook and four versus this rook and
three if you take this deep on and move
it over a file d5 or d6 it doesn't
matter the extra pawn becomes a passed
pawn and in that case the chances of
winning rise now we all know let's say
put the pawn on b5 we all understand the
defenders rook meets to be behind the
past pawn right
you put take this pawn and put the pawn
over here you take this rook put it over
here black moves his be pawn this King
comes like a beeline over to the B file
you eat f7 you eat h7 he makes a queen
you give up your rook and then it's a
race back over there to the King side
right any any rook ending where you have
a passed pawn your chances of winning
upon ahead go up quite a bit these
positions were your Bharath it of a
passed pawn should with best play always
be drawn but on the other hand you
should be able to put pressure on your
opponent
Vasiliy made it look easy
yeah and you had you also had a question
so yes King up let's say very good and
rook back king here alright and h4 so I
don't really want to take because that
kind of splits my pawn I lose some
structural integrity let me play a move
like h6 here kingi - and now I'm I'm
stuck I don't know how to further my
advantage
army
okay yeah so f-pawn hmm now I'm just not
a hundred percent sure let's say I take
take check now if I don't take the pawn
he's gonna trade so let's say I take he
comes over I got to practice my
highlight skill so I do every time I'm
attacking the pawn and let's say rook
here King up kind of feel like darn it I
I'm hitting the wall again
my extra pawn by the way this mechanism
this drawing mechanism as well as that
f3 drawing mechanism that's very very
common in these rook endings that the
defender has a way of totally ruining
the attackers pawn structure that
doubling up the pawns and stuff back
here again I have played this move
because I was very fearful of rook here
and h4 and again I think I should have
played oops sorry
not that one sorry yeah I think here in
this moment I might have tried I don't
think it would matter I think that in
fact that it's simply a draw but you
know only with the benefit of hindsight
I think I should have tried a variation
let me say just I want to get my yeah
I should have tried this move to stop my
opponent from playing rook a for N and H
for and then to try to have pressed from
here let's say King G to just as a as a
move h5 and I think his best move is
actually to play h3 and to meet h4 with
g4 okay so this is basically the best I
can achieve over on this side of the
board and now I really don't have
anything better than for example here
he's waiting he's waiting and I can
achieve more or less as a maximum
something like this then in this
position he steps backwards he controls
this rank so that I have nothing better
than rook here
rook here rook here hoping to be able to
step up with my king then I think he
should give me a check and go after one
of the loops see you see why I need to
practice my skills I can do this right
this and this so essentially this is
perhaps one of the best outcomes I can
achieve yeah as to get a position like
this he'll step back so essentially he's
waiting at some moment I'm going to have
to play f5 and as soon as I do play f5
he'll probably give me a check and we'll
get a three versus two
positional one other very important
point about the defenders rook it's an
interesting thing why did I choose a
three and not for example b3 arguably in
this position it probably doesn't make
any difference this is a very very good
principle of getting your rook as far
away from the king you want to check
from far away instead of from up close
yeah when you check up close the King
might crawl towards the rook and you run
out of checks when the rook is really
far away it's very hard after check King
back check to walk towards the rook
because then my King gets completely off
to this off to the wrong flank well
thank you all for coming as a special
treat I might say just take a look in
the database the game between Sarah one
that's me and Jonathan's Billman from
London Phillips and Dru there I want to
look in three verses rook into but it
was very very different all right thank
you all for coming have a good evening